[Music]
what is happening
it is january 17th
monday
and it is a big ass ufc week we got ufc
270
this mother trucking saturday it's going
down
for the biggest baddest belt on the
planet earth we're talking about the
heavyweight championship belt in the ufc
you got francis singano cyril gone it's
going down on saturday i can't freaking
wait
we also we got the calabasas fight
campaign with the boys brian callan
crystalia that is live only on the thick
boy youtube we will be live at 7 p.m
pacific for the main card tune in watch
this
monster of a main event wrestle card
making light you guys not a monster but
the main event the co-main
moreno my boy brandon moreno versus
figuerito what's poppin daddy
rest the cards not gonna blow your dick
off but
uh the main event coming event are worth
the money
now they did i'm sure chin will have it
in current events but they did uh
increase the price on espn which isn't
cool but uh
how much money do you need espn jesus
christ even dana was like i don't think
when they do that yeah i wonder if they
even ask him but uh great weekend man
great weekend uh it's good to be back
in the thick boy headquarters here
we had a busy one you know i knew
i told the team in december i said uh
you know december we're still with show
time you know still on their platform
and you know we're kind of doing our own
thing figuring things out started doing
companions on our own i said the real
work begins in january and boy i was not
lying
everybody's overworked including myself
you got uh
we shot our first
uh food truck diary on the think boy
network with my team uh which you know
used to be a showtime product but this
is the first one on
the think boy platform so that will drop
when we doing that wednesday
we drop it wednesday with sugar sean
o'malley one of my favorite people
um absolutely love the kid for multiple
reasons
but yeah flew him in uh he stayed in
venice
and then uh we did the food truck and
then we also did the classic uh
calabasas fight campaign where me and
sugar
sean sit down and watch kind of his
three most influential fights in his
career and that will also drop in
january so uh
a lot's going on man then we also added
a new kind of wrinkle to the food truck
where i partnered up with my boys in
suplex in philly where i get all my
cakes from uh suplex and philly my boy
mike out there because every food truck
i give the fighter a shoe that i think
represents them and uh sugar shot yeah
sugar shawn got a good one
sugar shawn got a really good shoe i
won't spoil it but he got a [ __ ] i've
never seen him in person and now i
really want them they are fired and to
be honest
i knew like he's obviously a fashion guy
he has his unique style with his hair
and all the chains and [ __ ] that he
wears but i thought he'd like oh thanks
dude these are cool but he was stoked he
was super stoked on these kicks so uh
it's a good time man on the the classic
fight companion we also have have a
little whiskey as well
and it's just uh
i get talked to him for freaking hours
man he's one of the best and that uh
that drops uh wednesday man hopefully
you guys dig it hope you guys dig it's
my team running this bad boy now so we
put a lot of effort into it so you're
gonna enjoy on wednesday the uh first
food truck on the thick boy network and
it's with uh my boy
suga
and uh yeah he's just a great dude man
just a really good dude uh
outside that uh crystalia first um
dates on the books and i think two and a
half years he did his first full weekend
at levity live in oxnard
and uh he had his boys come out and open
up form he had uh king botch is it
botchaboc
i think it's bach is it bach
i don't know if it was botch or bach so
i just kept calling king which was uh
when he left chris because it's weird to
keep calm king as a grown man that's a
god it's a bock or botch
so uh
he you know i've never met him before
he's [ __ ] funny man he's super super
big on social media like he has a ton of
followers i'm sure
yeah i you know
i didn't realize how uh
how you know i i
i just didn't realize you know obviously
he's he's
big off of uh yeah was it
vine and [ __ ] like that and something
like that all that stuff and then he
also has the commercial i think with uh
carl's jr or whatever but he uh
the thing about king is he um
he he was doing stand-up before he blew
up on while and out like he was big he
he was doing the stand up grind and then
obviously got famous
from wiling out and all that stuff and
his social media but he's a comic uh
at heart so you know i didn't know
either i mean i'm [ __ ] comic man i'm
around all the time but i i didn't
really know he opens up for joe coy you
know that he opens up for joe coy now so
um you know joe coyzen i can have just
any schmuck open up for him like king's
a beast man so ask chris i was like yeah
i've seen him a while now and stuff it's
one of my favorite shows but is he uh
just like stand up wise and chris like
oh dude yeah man he started as a
stand-up man i was like really he's like
yeah so uh i went out and watched his
show and he's a [ __ ] killer man he's
good
he was really good he's a monster super
nice guy too really really nice guy down
to earth
uh yeah he's a monster but it was just
good to see chris out there i think you
got to stand over he had five shows he
has stay innovation for all five
and uh
yeah man it was good to see chris i've
never seen him happier man his wife was
back there
brian came saturday night awesome um
yeah sure we'll talk about finding a kid
but
yeah it's great someone said quad damn
it chris looks like a child yeah my legs
are way bigger in cases aren't they yeah
well i also worked out a lot more than
chris so there's that
but uh he has a great weekend at oxnard
is weird because
i played there their opening night i
think six years ago five years ago and
the the manager it was just a nightmare
and i was gone never be back and i
already told my age i'm like never get
me an offer from oxnard ever again ever
he's like we're like one of the worst
writing clubs i've ever been to so i
haven't done it so when chris asked me
don't like did that levity live like the
night where he's like once last time he
played there dude i think the opening
week is no no it's a beast now he's
ain't lying it's great they've done way
better man so yeah it was great man it
was great had the kids all day baby mama
was uh
at a wedding shot the kids solo on
saturday and sunday took them to the
park
and uh yep got that sonic ice cream yeah
the little mexican vendors they have all
sorts of ice creams they [ __ ] love
them
here's the problem don't this is uh
daddy lesson number one for you new dads
out there uh don't dress your kids in
light colors and then stroll the park
and give them super colorful ice cream
my tiger shirt was completely destroyed
boston's was covered in that [ __ ]
whatever that popsicle is i don't know
what creepy [ __ ] popsicle that is
creepy dude it says comic on it
eyes are creepy yeah it's like some
[ __ ] clown on fentanyl but he enjoyed
it
that's him being like get off of me dude
how big [ __ ] their hands are
it's great man tiger's mouth he looks
insane what can you do
uh yeah man so i'm just excited that we
have a big ass
uh ufc oh you also got the post yeah
thick mudders [ __ ] is that next saturday
yeah uh next saturday boy better step up
his training
that's that's fear of shane garrett
binding he goes which died he's sticking
to for two weeks now homie that's
completely fair sir i do different diets
all the time i've been on
i mean i i guess technically you would
call it the carnivore diet uh which i
you know rogan was doing we had a
conversation about i'm like just meat
though dude and then
i gotta be honest it's the easiest diet
i've ever had to stick to i feel
fantastic i'm down nine pounds
um it's just easy
you eat like a [ __ ] big cat at the
zoo super easy anything that a [ __ ]
tiger would need at the zoo you don't
eat and then obviously because my teeth
are so sensitive not cavities in your
face dentist not cavities my teeth are
sensitive i can't have sugar so my
body's not even craving sugar so no
daddy doesn't want sugar now it's just
red meat
and you can have chicken stuff i'm not
[ __ ] with chicken or turkey pork none
of that i'm just really
just meat all the time i'm telling you
like would a [ __ ] lion eat chicken or
pork nah bruh it's red meat i'm like
before i came here i had a rib eye a rib
eye i had two rib eyes yesterday and
like five uh beef patties that's my diet
i'm not even hungry either i'm never i
have to like force myself to eat it
it's crazy not is it sustainable i don't
know
i don't know i'm gonna look like jared
let him three months if i stick with it
probably like a lot of you eyes might
change to [ __ ] blue or green or
whatever it is there but um yeah i don't
it's been super easy for me man
and then brogan was talking about how he
heats uh
he added fruit into his so to better
workouts i'm not even [ __ ] with fruit
daddy
you ever seen a lion in the zoo [ __ ]
grapes
never they eat that raw red meat son
that's what i'm doing so we'll see
uh biked almost 40 miles yesterday no
issue my mental uh clarity is fantastic
never hungry no cravings losing weight
workouts have been good
so we'll see yeah there's 10 spots left
it's next saturday january 29th it's
lake elsinore
it's orange county they say los angeles
and i also promote los angeles
and you think i'd look into it more but
i didn't but uh
it's it's definitely not la is it it's
about uh hour and a half hour 45 from
here it's orange county it's in the
sticks of orange county and uh the whole
squad's running man so there's 10 spots
left to run with the thick boys squad
you got brian callan chappelle lacy my
boy casey's doing it you got freaking uh
big j shaub is doing it you got
christian meatball doing it and i think
we've had over 50 other thick fans sign
up for it so there's 10 spots left man
um you know what we didn't want just a
bunch of thickies running this thing you
know they were like well let's limit to
some people so there's 10 left and that
was yesterday so who knows it's still
available but that is 10 a.m next mother
truck and saturday man i'm excited for
it it's gonna be a great time
uh let's get to some fights though
obviously all i want to talk about is
francis cyril gunn but we can't because
i told you guys you're gonna get a great
fight on saturday night
uh and calvin kater versus uh your boy
giga
says oh
how do i want to jump in this i would
say i was surprised um
you know calvin's been on the show
multiple times i absolutely love calvin
and he's from you know the new england
cartel uh the winter hill gang boys out
there in boston shout out to whitey
bulger but um
yeah i i really thought this would be a
tougher fight for calvin i i thought uh
if he was gonna pressure giga whose legs
were gonna get tore up i thought gee was
the more crisp striker
um clearly on defeating the ufc 7-0 for
a reason
wasn't crazy about the matchup for
calvin especially after the max hallway
fight
but jesus christ how [ __ ] tough is
calvin cater he i mean giga didn't went
around it
the the 50 44 i'm i'm with you man yeah
that was that fight was not close at all
and the the timing of his elbows and the
spinning back fists and he beat the [ __ ]
out of giga i mean it that fight was not
that competitive it was a uh a slobber
knocker
but because calvin cater made it that
way you know he he was trying to take
him out of there he couldn't do it shows
you how freaking tough giga is he gives
me fine he has world champion written
all over him and maybe a loss is good
for him but uh you know as he got tired
i think he was surprised at how a how
hard calvin hit
b the pressure calvin and then also see
how the leg kicks with the distance and
the pressure really [ __ ] up his game
plan which i would assume was to to kick
a lot more but when calvin scored that
uh takedown the first round and kind of
you know didn't go for broke wore giga
out and then once you started landing
shots on them the cardio was an issue
for giga so uh shout out to calvin kadar
man right back in the queue for a title
shot right back there because they're
talking about oh if giga wins he's next
well where's calvin he beat the [ __ ] out
of him i mean he lost to max holloway
but you know matt just hurt so calvin
completely redeemed himself and he is
right back in the queue for a title shot
featherweight man he looked phenomenal
now
like so i was messaging with tyson his
coach like their game plan and just how
they did everything together it was like
flawless man
everyone did regardless the takedown was
great the timing and the takedowns was
great and what he scored three takedowns
two the the two there's two like main
main ones we're like holy [ __ ] that one
he slipped and he took advantage of it
right away oh man that changed
everything too yep yep and then that's
what wore uh giga out so shout out to
him and
bram roy roy val got it done to split
decision i did have him winning that
which is fine needed him to win that but
uh that was a good
first fight in 2022 man just to wet your
beaks for the big ufc this freaking
weekend man
big ufc this weekend god if you're a
football fan and ufc fan things are
popping right now i know it sounds like
a draftkings ad it's not i'm just saying
you got the wild card playoffs which i
watched [ __ ] every game
and then you got you know the next
tonight my rams oh listen i'm from
denver so i'm a broncos fan
but in la it's you got to be good rams
fans it's all they show rams are
chargers i watch all their games we get
the rams tonight for arizona
and then uh yeah clearly the cowboys do
what they do best they lose and then uh
uh freaking uh was it dak start blame
the refs when they're like hey they're
throwing trash like it's just surprising
fans would do that after all the hard
work were put in and the one the uh
journalists like well no they're
throwing trash at the ref and he's like
oh
that's fine that's fine and he's just
getting
freaking trashed for that no pun
intended
but yeah man it's a great uh week to be
a fight sports fan in general dude i you
know there's nothing better than playoff
football and then also you got there's
there's nothing bigger than the
heavyweight title there's nothing like
it
and the ufc knows that and that's why
you look at the rest of the car and
again it's not going to knock your dick
off but
it doesn't matter you're paying the
money for that main event fight man and
that's why we're doing a freaking fight
campaigning for it i can't [ __ ] wait
i cannot wait
i uh
[Music]
you know i think about francis and sir
ghana a ton
probably more than i should because i'm
not fine anymore but uh
you know the the this you know i went on
the rant last week and it was one of the
clips you didn't see it on how if you're
a fight fan and you care about the
fighters you want francis to win because
what he's doing is history for fighters
um and it's very rare a guy will let a
guy fight when he doesn't have an
extended contract already
signed it's very very rare that they
then fight for the world heavyweight
title
and in hopes that they can come to
common ground and sign a contract
extension after that
knowing francis and his team they have
no desire to resign with ufc their plan
is for francis to knock out sirogon and
then go test free agency in hopes of
getting the tyson fury in hopes of
getting a wilder fight and getting [ __ ]
you money that's their plan and i gotta
be honest i'm surprised the ufc is open
to it
i think they think they're going to
figure out a contract
but i don't think they realize that the
team at caa has different plans unless
they offer him some just insane deal and
i made this argument to suga when he was
on food truck which you guys would hear
on wednesday
i you know i i made the argument that
sugar represents himself which is fine
some guys do i i wouldn't advise it
for a number of reasons which i could
get into later but sugar represents
himself
and also francis and you'll see some of
these other big names
you know with the ufc discrepancy and
the issues they have with ufc their
model is not what it was five years ago
and these agents and managers are going
off an old model where the ufc uh was
predicated on
pay-per-view buys and superstars their
model has changed and for people not to
realize that is insane to me because
you've already lost at the negotiation
table if you don't know what animal
you're dealing with
and you can see with ufc does ufc need
stars to stay relevant 100 i'm not
saying that
but the ufc doesn't need superstars
to
be profitable not anymore you know back
in the day it was all you know how many
more pay-per-views was there and you
know that's why connor made so much
money and stuff like that and you know
the brock lesnar and ronda rousey's of
the world and ancient silvas and
bispings and you know these these
champions made all this money because it
was predicated off a pay-per-view model
well they've gone away from that and the
biggest indicator too is just look at
them charging more for
you know to espn plus and even the
pay-per-views going up so
all the ufc cares about is fulfilling
their espn contract
and
espn listen as much you guys want to
think that they're these huge fight fans
and they know the game they don't know
[ __ ]
just like when the ufc was fox i was
working with fox i would be with the
head honchos and they would bring up
[ __ ] like you think chocolate l comes
back well where's brock lesnar if all
they knew was chuck brock conor mcgregor
that's it that was when conor's coming
up that was it man outside that they
have no [ __ ] clue what's going on
so you know espn all they care is that
the the that the ufc fulfills their
obligation to them which is 40-something
fights a year
um and they don't care who's on them
they don't care so it gives the ufc more
leverage which is a shame but it gives
them more leverage
to let guys walk because if this is five
years ago
francis ain't fighting for a world title
without having a contract uh negotiated
it ain't happening they net usually they
would negotiate two fights before
because you know and if you didn't they
would throw you to the [ __ ]
wolverines you would get the worst
matchups possible and that's them trying
to teach you a lesson but it's also them
trying to devalue where if you were to
lose when you go to free agency it kind
of [ __ ] you over so you'd have to play
ball with them
we're just live in a different time
we're live in a different time i think
agents of managers need to realize that
and
they're
it's not going to work for everybody
this is my
rant to suga and i you know i talked to
ca this morning my rant to them was
you know
the ufc is going to be fine without
francis the ufc is fine without jon
jones the ufc moved on from ronda rousey
the ufc is fine without amanda nunes the
ufc is fine without you know name it
insert any henry cejudo and and i'm sure
it's in your current mention but
that's why the ufc doesn't they don't
budge like with henry cejudo they're not
even open to it like how much does he
want we're good as long as volkonovsky
fights somebody and fulfills his
obligations we fulfill the espn we're
good we're not going to fork out more
money for a guy
it's just that's their business model
kudos to them it's smart that they're
not you know
banking on them having super strong
superstars all the time but back to
francis
you have to be an and this is why you
want francis to win this fight it's not
that i don't like cyril gone i actually
said he was gonna be champ i think two
years ago if you go back and let's blow
the belt his movement and how technical
he is and his athletic ability he's an
outlier amongst outliers at the
heavyweight uh
division he's an absolute nightmare for
anyone not a knockout artist and i think
that might hurt him in the long run but
again the uc doesn't care but
he's a guy who at heavyweight with his
footwork and he's so technical he's
gonna outclass most of these guys and
it's you know it's not gonna be these
crazy highlights on espn stuff like that
he's just gonna win it's gonna be very
difficult to beat said that two years
ago so here we are he's fighting for a
title shot
the reason you should cheer for francis
is to be because he's an outlier and
because again this morning i'm sure you
guys woke up saw the news that jake paul
made 40 million dollars he says that's
actually uh undervalued of how much he
made this year whatever it is 40 50 60
million doesn't matter
if it if it was 15 million he's making
more than most ufc fighters so
by more i mean all of them besides conor
so my thing here is
francis is an outlier again it's not
going to work for everybody there's
there's five and i i list them off last
week but there's about five or six guys
who can do this but what jake say what
you want about jake paul but what he's
done to shed light on how much power
there is in controlling your own destiny
destiny and banking on yourself
and taking your career into your own
hands and not banking on the machine of
the ufc you know they see these huge
numbers that jake paul is doing
and it's it's giving guys like francis
like moz vidal
like the diaz brothers like conor
mcgregor and insight going i i could
probably do this on my own and take all
the money instead of using the middleman
the ufc i can make life-changing money
which i'm deserved and every every
friend you see should have
life-changing money for what they're
doing they should that's not the way the
business model works and you know that's
not realistic but there's five guys who
can do it france is one of those guys
and this is he can only do it if he wins
on saturday night and this is why i want
him to win
because if he wins again you're talking
about
a crossover fight with tyson fury and
tyson fury's you know even promoting it
talking about it and you're talking 30
40 million dollars for francis do you
not want to see a ufc guy
stick it to the ufc and i'm you guys
know this i'm i bleed ufc men i one of
the reasons i left showtime so i don't
have to cover other organizations i am
ufc alumni i love the ufc i love
everything about the ufc nobody can
compete with them nobody has the roster
like them nobody's better at business
than them nobody puts on a show like
them nobody's smarter than them it is
what it is man haters are going to hate
everybody hates the guy at the top
that's why the ufc gets the [ __ ] that
they get but there's a reason for that
because of the top dog
do you not want to see a guy beat that
system and it's not that i want
ufc to go away or you know to to do bad
or anything like that i just want a guy
in francis who came from africa a
[ __ ] working diamond mines with sand
mines what the [ __ ] you was doing
you know and he's the heavyweight
champion he's one of the greatest
knockouts we've ever seen
i just want him to lead the path to show
other guys at his level
that you ca there's something else
there's more out there for you there's
more and it's so much more intriguing
his story's so much more intriguing if
he does accomplish that
because it's like remember the guy that
broke the i think it was a four minute
mile remember that and then a a year
goes by and 20 people broke the
four-minute mile once humans realize
once fighters realize that they can do
this man it's off to the races and
francis can be that first guy it's jake
paul's jake paul shed light on it but
jake paul's not one of us jake paul
didn't go through the rankings of the
ufc and through the hardship and dealing
with ghost negotiations and the reebok
deal and now the venom deal and you know
getting [ __ ] fights and fighting abu
dhabi and just all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you gotta deal with being professional
athlete
jake paul didn't go through that but he
did shed light on if you do take
ownership of your career and you are at
that level you can make so much more
money man and what they're doing you
know it's it's life-threatening you know
you know the end of
when you're at the tail end of your life
you're going to suffer for what you did
when you're in your 20s 30s and some 40s
because you're getting punched in the
face and they're more than likely you're
going to have some form of brain trauma
or slurs speech or you know back issues
or knee issues you should be compensated
so
francis needs to win on on [ __ ]
saturday again this isn't a knock on
sarah i'd love sarah i think he's going
to be champ
i just don't be champ on saturday
because i want francis to win because
it's going to pave the way for every
other big name to go francis did it and
now think about francis did it and he
did just based off skills
once last time you saw france give you a
hot promo when's the last time francis
did a [ __ ] tick-tock dance or [ __ ]
did some crazy thing on ig that went
viral besides him just like punching
ryan garcia in the stomach or something
like that you know what i'm saying he's
he doesn't check all the boxes as far as
being entertaining
[ __ ] ferrari and rolex and bend over
backwards to sign francis and gano
they're not but because he's such a good
fighter because he's the face of the
heavyweight division and because he went
i'm gonna bank on myself
there's
you guys have to appreciate that even if
you're from [ __ ] france you need to
root for francis and gano because if he
fails at this
everybody's [ __ ]
then we don't have this lane you want
this lane and it was started by jake
paul and if you hate what he represents
or that he didn't earn it or whatever
whatever weird thing you have in your
head that makes you hate jake paul
you have to appreciate that he has shed
light on something that nobody's ever
been able to do and if two years ago you
told me jake paul would have been the
pioneer
to show us
what these fighters are capable of doing
i'm like if jake paul's gonna do it
he did it
he did it and now we need one of our
guys to do it because if one of our guys
do it it's gonna be like the guy that
broke the four-minute mile there's gonna
be a bunch of other people that break
that [ __ ] barrier and it starts with
francis and gano on saturday night and
boy does he have a tough task to do
and that's what i think is so admirable
that
he's banking himself man
he's banging himself and everybody knows
how the ufc works if he were to lose
this fight
that fury fight probably goes out the
window he can test free agency but um
maybe he'd make a little more if he
signs with other organizations but
you're basically off into the ether and
nobody cares
i'd love to see evidence or statistics
that shows me one person that in the
height of the ufc career left and went
on become more famous and more relevant
i'll wait go
we can go through them if you want i'm
open to discussion
my guy at starbucks who makes my drink
always wants to argue with me so if you
have anything dude um before you make my
eight shot espresso think of it because
i'll be there tomorrow morning and i you
i assume you represent the internet i'd
be down to argue that um it's just
the the enormity of what francis is
doing and bacon himself
is uh
it's a lot man and i [ __ ] with those
people
yeah he's called an outlier he's banging
himself any entrepreneur has done it
where you could have taken a big job
somewhere for a corporation but you're
banking on yourself
that you're going to be able to put the
puzzle pieces together and at the end
it's going to benefit you more and
you're doing it your way well francis is
doing it his way and if you've ever been
that person to get online or when you're
watching ufc fights go man i wish you
got paid more
you have to root for francis
no matter how you feel about sirogon
you people in france that are watching
this
i know it sucks you want a french
champion
not right now not right now the the
magnitude of what francis represents is
so much bigger than you have enough
champion from france
it's big it's bigger than this this is
bigger than the game and it's very rare
this happens what happens on saturday
night francis wins
is history not only being a heavyweight
champion it's history because he's gonna
go on and do something nobody's ever
done
you should root for him
it's a tough fight for him
he's an underdog
do you not root for the underdog that's
banking on himself
now if you're part of the machine and
you want to you know what you want the
ufc and again
with francis moving on
the ufc's models not predicate on
francis sticking around they don't
really care hate to tell you guys that's
another reason you should root for
francis the ufc's fine amount they're
making their this exact same amount of
money if francis leaves or stays with
their espn deal
so why would you not root for francis oh
i don't like that i don't what don't you
like he knocks dudes out
well i want cyril gondwin i'm with you
man i think cyril's gonna be a champ i'm
telling you if you want things to change
for the better you have got to root for
francis this saturday and even though
all of us are rooting for francis i
don't know if it's enough for him to win
but
what he's fighting for is so much bigger
than the heavyweight title he's fighting
for [ __ ] history and he's gonna be
the first guy to ever
follow in jake paul's footsteps and go
outside the ufc banking himself and get
these [ __ ] you money fights that's what
we're rooting for guys and it's history
it's [ __ ] history and if you can't
[ __ ] with that you ain't [ __ ] how about
that
um let's talk about the fight
easier said than done isn't it there's a
reason he's an underdog
there's a few things working against
francis
uh the number one thing that alarms me
being a big big francis fan
he hasn't had much time in the octagon
even when he fought knocked on his last
how many chin is under you know you're
talking about
just to give this is this probably being
generous it's under two minutes you know
so his last fight
was march 2021
it basically went one round so you got a
round around in
before that
he weighed damn near the entire year
he beat rosenstein right you guys said
rosenstruck was gonna be a tough test
for him that's cool uh he beat rosen
stroke in 20 seconds
in 2020 he spent
20 seconds
doing his job
then in 2019 he knocked out june dos
santos in basically a minute min 11.
before that he beat cain velasquez in 26
seconds before that he beat curtis
blades in 45 seconds
so in
four years
he has spent i'm gonna round up here he
has spent one two
a little over three minutes inside that
gun
that's alarming
that's alarming
that worries me
because i
i don't think this can be a quick fight
for francis um and i know he's
definitely gotten better uh after that
steep a loss and he's matured i and i
don't know if technically he's gotten
better i know his coaches say that of
course that's it but it has been [ __ ]
four years since he lost to stipe so i
would assume
he's gotten better but i think he's
matured more which which is an advantage
for francis
so
can francis get him out there and under
a minute again for sure
what worries me is when that bad boy
gets in that third round fourth round
the fifth round we know cyril gone uh
is built to go five rounds he's banking
himself going five rounds that's what he
likes to do um you look at a lot of his
fights they're not they're not quick
matter of fact he has no quick fights
he doesn't do quick
he does calculated he does footwork
and um that that worries me the most
going into this fight
but on the other side of that you can
say that serogon has never been in a
major fight yay fought rosenstroke is a
ufc fight night yay volkov is a fight
night it was five rounds
but fighting for the world heavyweight
title on a major
ufc pay-per-view is a different animal
francis has done that and the first time
he did that he was cocky about it and he
got humbled he got humbled but he
learned from that and that's why i give
francis the advantage in this fight
sierra gone hasn't learned he's had no
learning experiences in the in the
octagon
so you gotta bank on his experience in
the big title fights francis has been
there he's learned that
and then also if you're gonna bet on
francis you also got to bet on do you
guys really think
for 25 minutes 25 [ __ ] minutes in
that big cage that cyril gone can avoid
one punch from francis all we need is
one
all we need is one punch if you're a
francis fan you need one punch on the
[ __ ] button
in 25 minutes and he's your world
heavyweight champion he changes the
course of every major superstar in the
ufc from here on out
i like his odds
i like his odds
i think for francis i bet i would be
willing to bet that his camp has really
focused on conditioning
because
the best thing about sarah gone is his
footwork and he's gonna have to cut him
off easier said than done
and it's not gonna be easy to do early
on it's just not gonna happen early on
so francis has to hopefully corner him
cut him off to be able to land one of
those punches even with tight quarters
i'll take it
but what we don't if you're a francis
fan what you don't want is this fight at
a distance this fight is at a distance
sirogon is winning in every way possible
on the scorecards
with kicks and his you know his jab and
he's too technical he's not getting hit
we need francis to blitz him which he's
going to do what i do like is
cyril's a big guy don't get me wrong but
he doesn't have that god-given knockout
power like francis has
so even if francis were to charge in
and cyril is going to counter i'm not
worried about him knocking out francis
opposed to sarah to rush francis you're
gonna get knocked the [ __ ] out
so
that's also another chip in francis's
corner where
he can he can
risk a little more get a little sloppy
you're gonna get touched now you can put
a combo together or kick to the face and
knock them the [ __ ] out cyril's also a
big dude so you don't let that happen
too often but we can get away with one
or two before your lights are turned off
francis you get away with nothing we
need one little mistake we need one
should a zigg when he should have you
know zagged and he's if the fight's over
and francis wins
i'm banking on that i'm banking on the
moment's too big for cyril gone i'm
banking on francis realizes what he's
fighting for
hopefully because his learning
experience in the stipe fight that he he
does well under this pressure it's not
too much for him and he comes out on top
i'm taking francis
via ko under three rounds
and all of you should take francis via
ko
every one of you should be hoping for
that again not because you're a francis
fan or chill gone fan because it's
better for every other superstar that's
ever going to fight in the ufc it's
life-changing because if he fails all
this goes out the window can he go to
freichi like i told you yeah sure he can
go to the free agency
but his value is nowhere near is is
tyson fury gonna fight you know francis
who doesn't have a title shot or a
heavyweight title belt no
he's not all that goes out the window he
has to knock him out he has to have the
belt and he has to ride off in the
sunset and go test free agency
all uh tyson fury joshua wilder that's
what we want
i'm nervous already
let's take a little break from me
really ranting about the
magnitude that francis faces this
saturday ufc 270. let's take a little
break because you're going to be
watching you'll be watching the fight on
pay-per-view you're going to be tuning
in to the cobb ass fight companion with
your boy available only on think boy
youtube you'll be tuning in all that but
you know what makes all this better if
you're betting some money yep you got
money riding on it you got money right
on ufc 270 this saturday be sure to
check out my friends at
draftkingsportsbook that's right i get a
special parlay for you guys they're
going to boost your odds all you got to
do is go to the brennan shop tab on
draftkings you will see i have a three
man parlay all three have to win in
order for you to make bank bro i got
adolfo vieira brandon moreno and francis
ingano if all three of them win you make
bank and they're going to boost your
odds with draftkings
that's right ufc 270 there's no better
spot to make money with draftkings when
you sign up you can boost your odds when
you do the brenden shop picks just click
on the tab bar for the brennan shop
picks again vieira moreno francine gano
all right
you place your bets watch the fist fly
this weekend the heavyweight title is on
the line must be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only restrictions
play see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details gambling problem call 100
gambler or an indiana 1 809 with it with
draftkings enter promo code shob or shop
show woo doggy the the thick boy crew
made it through the holiday rush man but
you can't slack you can't let your guard
down you got to get shipping to your
customers on time all right or exchanges
you got to do it we do it with all the
think boy merch which we have a drop
this thursday see the coat your boys
wearing thick boy car club is coming in
hot all right but my friends my friends
at ship station got you covered shipping
delays supply shortage holiday demand
last year was a hot mess now you're
ringing the new year with impatient
customers returns expensive shipping
rates it's time to switch to a shipping
solution that can handle
all this painlessly we got you man why
would you use anything but ship station
it's easy it's convenient all right most
e-commerce sellers choose ship station
all right uh you can save time because
you're funneling all your orders in one
simple interface no matter what you're
selling manage every order amazon ebay
etsy your own website like thick boy
from anywhere even your freaking phone
you save money go ahead compare with
other carry options all right
they're the best man you choose the best
shipping solution every single time ship
station works with every carrier so you
can always find the best fit for you
all right and also peace of mind knowing
your orders are handled and getting the
best rates make shipping the easiest
part of having an online store you have
bigger ideas to think about than all
this stuff man no wonder ninety percent
of companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business it's that freaking
good ship more and less time with ship
station use the code shobb s-e-h-a-u-b
to get 60-day free trial that's too much
free no hassle stress free shipping just
go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone the top of the
page type in shob s-e-h-a-u-b ship
station make ship happen
i think brandon moreno in the co-main
event just has figuerito's number
he uh he absolutely dominated that that
that second time and uh it's just
brandon's time
you'll hear you know wonder boy is the
nicest guy or this guy's a nice skinny
fc or francis is nice or dc's nice stipe
is nice nobody is [ __ ] nicer than
bran moreno he's too nice you know when
someone's too nice you think they're gay
you know what i'm saying like what is
what's this guy's agenda here what's he
trying to thought i was gay for quite
some time too so yeah i think some
comics think i'm gay because he's too
nice
but
he's shredded yeah super shredded now
yep
that's not his initiation
let's test the guy on the right but uh
that's not his issue the issue is that
him being shred city and having better
cardio his issue is adapting your brand
moreno yeah and the in the onslaught of
the takedowns and the kicks and the
punches
so you know i'm not well i know
everyone's like have you seen how
shreddy is i don't give a [ __ ] about
that they're also flyweights so you
better be
shredded so yeah again the rest card
you you don't worry about the rest of
the card so card's really not [ __ ] but
uh hadolfo's fun too
yeah the rest cards whatever man but you
you're the ko and main event especially
that main event the magnitude that's
riding on france's shoulders is so
insane
well now i'm like super hyped
changed the course of the history of all
ufc superstars name the last fight
you've had like this that
that someone has had this opportunity
that's why you cheer from all right what
do you got jun
all right
i just talked about francis for two
hours i know and i'm like do you know
when francis was three
that his mom everyone was like that was
like
that's a long time
about half an hour i ran thinking about
why she went yeah that's good though i
feel like it's important it is uh so he
was francis was talking to i think brett
okamoto on espn
about how his contract how he wants his
contract to be uh so he said something
like he's not gonna fight anymore for
500 or 600 thousand dollars and would he
would have to have an open clause to box
just to stay in the ufc
it gets dicey i you know
if i if i'm the ufc you know
and again i know their model's not
predicated off superstars anymore in
pay-per-views but
i mean if he could come to agreement
where he could still
you know maintain a career in the ufc
and get those fights like they did with
connor yeah and the ufc wants him boxing
but my if i'm
francis's uh agents i'm going we're down
for this but what's your cut like how
much are you guys taking
that's where it gets dicey
so you guys know i will not fight for
500 600 000 anymore
um i mean it's over it's over i just did
this i took this fight for a personal
reason i want to make sure regardless
even if it's unfair i've been wrongly
treated i can make my case say i've
completed the eight fights but no
the
the contract is pretty cool i think it
says here that if he does win the the
championship he would just sit out for
the year and i guess after a year goes
by the ch you know you don't have to be
uh
your contract's over with basically you
have to have three fights
or
wait out a year so he's like i'll wait
out a year
uh and that's if he becomes everybody
yeah if he wins a championship he's just
he'll just wait out i'll fight for a
year and the contract will be over
i think even with the ufc like i know
you don't want to set up presidents here
but
that's like you have to wait out a year
just
do are you do are you not making enough
money like can the guy just move on you
know what i'm saying yeah
um
so he had a five-year term however he
said the champions class in the country
all states they should hold the title
at its expiration he would be bound to
promote for one year or three fights
that all makes me think it's optional
also yeah
what's interesting too it's like
it's so one-sided towards the ufc and
that's why the biggest organization
could have the best lawyers the best
contracts but
how quick was the ufc to give an intern
belt to cyril gone
i think you know it's like they'll just
make up these belts yeah
they're gonna do they have to wait a
year do they have to wait three fights
no but the champ does like it's so
one-sided
uh ingano seemed unclear status given
the congress overlooked term the
championship clause at 1.7 he wouldn't
be under contract until january 2023
because the global the the global of the
ufc contract from the beginning to the
end it cannot pass five years it's
confusing
yeah it's all confusing but you said
they had the best lawyers i'm sure they
thought about all their sponsors yeah
trust me
but all
these big businesses that like the nfl
has the best lawyers the ufc has the
best lawyers [ __ ] mgm universal these
big movie marvel they have the best
lawyers
so you can't you you can't [ __ ] him over
you're not going to be able to get all
your shine and just dip out like you're
not gonna be able to play [ __ ] iron
man for marvel then just dip out and
play you know
a different thor [ __ ] it just doesn't
work like that
what else you got all right this is
pretty cool so colby covington versus
jorge mazda
official the headline ufc 272 in march i
love that fight oh yeah love that fight
so interesting how mozval is going to
look in that fight i would assume
obviously i was a underdog in that oh
yeah i mean so colby's a big
favorite
minus three three three thirty or
something like that
yeah
yeah i mean you know this is one of
those fights where
if it were to go
you know past the third and fourth that
means colby's definitely doing work but
mozville doll has that [ __ ] mentality
where flying knees and you know where
it's something that kobe hasn't had to
really deal with before where mazda has
that he doesn't give a [ __ ] he gets
taken down and he's he's going for broke
he's trying to finish you which which
you know isn't a bad idea to put some
money on mazda because he does have the
power but i'm curious how he's going to
look and come back after getting
literally flat lined by kamal usman you
know
and you mentioned before too when you
fight because there were homies they
were training partners when you fight
that it's just different right you guys
changed your approach yeah you know what
that guy's really good at so you
usually things you would do you don't
because you think he knows what's coming
so
um
you know i
i it's been a while so i think this
won't be one of those fights like that
but this fight the build up it's just
brilliant matchmaking yeah i mean you
know former roommates teammates like
this is a great [ __ ] fight
storyline's awesome yeah the storyline
writes its [ __ ] self okay so this is
a quick one on korean zombie um well
let's do this one first
so after giga lost
korean zombie
not like himself just tweeted out
something like you know
yeah hand to the face and of course
gigan obviously didn't like that
well it comes from too that giga was
saying like volkanov's gonna take the
easy route and take you talks a lot of
smack dude yeah but he was like it's no
shade on korean zombie but you look at
his possible
guys he can fight like
korean zombies the easiest one he's
going to go with that he's like he's no
shade on he's like but he's ranked i
think 10 or something like that he's
saying
so this is korean zombie no this uh this
is uh no i'm saying this is that was
korean zombie doing the emoji
i'm guessing that's
him like firing back at that
i just i never like when fighters [ __ ]
on other fighters when they lose yeah
especially korean zombies i know it
doesn't make sense i don't think cruz
zombie did that
you know this gotta agree with you he
has a team running
he's like so respectful yeah that's why
we love korean zombie his team
clearly isn't they create so many issues
for him he get you know
you'd think they would learn after brian
ortega slapped homeless no like why keep
doing this man and you're fighting for a
title so there's no
we don't need this you already got what
you wanted
so uh gigapa thank you uh thank you my
real supporters i love you all i owe you
speed comeback
speedy comeback a lot of fake people
around but it's okay also [ __ ] you
korean zombie be happy with someone's uh
loss you cheap [ __ ]
yeah
you would be upset yeah then i saw
this is what zombie posted afterwards
too calm down and rest with the
sweaty thing i just don't see korean
zombie get on instagram story restoring
this then putting that emoji
do i i'm not buying it at all i'm with
you on that yeah
okay and you mentioned that
korean zombie is now it's official that
he's going to fight alexander
volkonovsky
yeah it's official and then we mentioned
last weekend below the belt how korean
zombie put out a post about his shoulder
and how he's out for a long time
and then again he's not we didn't hear
from korean zombie we hear from his
manager like no he's fine yeah well well
march he said he was out for like a year
but that year's title shot no his
shoulder is [ __ ] great man
well i didn't hear him say that
yeah so he said the shoulder is good we
were planning on fighting late in april
early may which is kind of what i was
suggesting ufc beforehand really because
your fighter beg to differ
opportunity came out we're ready to go
it's just timeline a little earlier
being a fight ready being in there as
well they have great camp there
facilities we ready to go
yeah i think this would be a tough night
in the office for green zombies and he
messed up his shoulder before too yep
yeah yeah
and uh
yeah so this is dana white talking about
how
henry cejudo doesn't deserve a title
shot right away and what do you say
about it
he said isn't he retired basically
right here
uh so white on henry stuart said isn't
the guy retired he's retired isn't he i
mean last time i saw him he was retired
now he's mad that he didn't get a touch
that doesn't even make sense different
weight class doesn't make sense
here's the problem with this is uh
you know if dana doesn't want again they
don't care if the hooter comes back i'm
telling you guys with their new business
model but
it's very rare people at dana's level
that's why you admire joe rogan at his
level hud made if he makes a mistake or
if he doesn't know something
dana doesn't have that capability i
guess you know or maybe he just didn't
think about it but when he says this
isn't what we do you can't be retired
and come back in and
gsp did that and he
took way more time off than him he's
retired quote-unquote way longer than
henry so don't say you don't do it or it
doesn't work like that because you've
done that
what you should have said is
we're not into these guys being retired
then jumping in different weight classes
getting belts and dipping out we learn
from gsp as a mistake we're not going to
do that again just own it what it is
yeah or say
he wants too much money we're just not
into it we're going to do the korean
zombie fight but don't say it doesn't
work like that
because anybody who knows the game
outside the casuals on espn or whatever
they're gonna be like yeah it doesn't
work like that we've all seen it where
it does work like that we've actually
seen it work like that pretty recently
too and there's so many
statistics and numbers that go against
your argument that doesn't that's
exactly how it works you're just not a
henry pseudo fan or you don't want to
pay him it would be so refreshing if
he's like
henry's great and it would be cool to be
a you know three division champion
what he's asking for is crazy we're
gonna pay him that then also we let a
guy who was more retired took more time
off than his pseudo and gsb comeback he
got the belt and he's never fighting
again kind of [ __ ] things up for us
doesn't make a lot of sense so we're
gonna pass
you know how cool that would be and then
say henry cerdo's not talking [ __ ]
everyone's like i get it but with this
when you go it doesn't work like that
every fan's like what that makes sense
so i i don't know i just can't be real
but again these high-level ceo stuff
like it's very rare they admit mistakes
or they're open-minded very rare
and he also mentioned that
why should be able to jump over you know
jump the line and just hop in but he's
done that before
again
i'll go to the history books
uh so what about the rumors that
conor mcgregor is going to fight charles
oliveira
later this year in the summer
it does work like that
it definitely works like that there's
guys that jump to the queue all the time
it doesn't make sense yeah dana's a
smart guy
and this is a bunch of different things
that
cejudo was tweeting about so dana was
white wasn't impressed with the idea of
letting cejudo skip the queue and said
this guy's retired he's been off how
many years now a lot less than just b uh
he wants to come and fight volkanovsky
for pseudo to retire and think you just
should just be able to come in and jump
into any weight division and take down
the champion that's not how it works it
is how it works seo protested white
claims there you go pointing to george
st pierre as a clear example of how it
can be done so if i had blonde hair blue
eyes or if i was canadian with an accent
maybe would give it to me i defend both
belts on like gsp facts i left on top
retired that monday to give the rest of
the division a chance you are playing
out scared that i will win
um
um
here we go
so you put dana oh so did white isn't
interested in having this [ __ ] silly
conversation about henry who to return
see my thing is why do you gotta
disrespect those guys like [ __ ] it's
not silly it's the only fight that we
wanted to see
though i like korean zombie i don't know
but i won i didn't pay for that dude
is it free
uh it's gotta be right it's championship
so
i'm sorry it's got to be pay for you
yeah
i mean do you do you want me to legally
stream this you know what i'm saying
doing these matchups uh and then henry's
so dana says i'm not interested in
having these [ __ ] silly conversations
that's where you offend the fighter and
he put dana i need a break obviously it
was getting boring beating up tj
dillashaw
yeah i know i just gonna be friendly
dylan shaw in under a minute and dominic
snoozing two i got married had a kid and
now i'm rejuvenated i want to be 4c if i
beat up an old guy at a bar and learn
how to river dance will you give me a
shot yeah
given all reps is the con or gsp
and for dsa it doesn't work it's just
not good enough dude at the level you're
operating at this isn't good enough
these aren't the the early 2000s where
everyone's like okay no dude we know
exactly how it works
no matter for sure not only do we know
exactly how it works we've all seen it
and this is why henry studio thought he
could do this because you've done it
before
this isn't new if this was the first
time i think most fans like yeah dude
you've been retired you can't just jump
in yeah but we've seen it someone's like
well
no
what do you mean it doesn't work like
this we we've seen him multiple times
dude
if dan just like when we let guys who
are retired jump in get the belt and dip
out it [ __ ] it just [ __ ] everything
up we're not into that but if he wants
to come back and take a warm-up fight
then we'd be interested in it
it's all good dude you don't have to
devalue the product you have to talk
[ __ ] call it a [ __ ] silly
conversation you have to do any of that
just be cool man
you got money be cool daddy
yeah that would be refreshing if you did
that
uh this was actually funny after henry
posted that of course connor yeah i
think he deleted at this point he goes
henry henry cejudo is a little fart
that's that's always tweeted right and
then this is what henry came back with
what do you know about farting you
always run out of gas god hilarious
and they put uh
excellent notorious i have nothing but
respect for you hopefully when i see you
we can shake hands you can do a line off
my head jesus christ rosa red lebanon
start henderson is only a little fart
interesting
all right uh two quick ones just a fight
announcements misha tate and lauren
murphy
what weight class
i'm pretty sure 135.
uh 125 right she expected 125 yeah for
illinois against lauren murphy
all right bam love that yep let's get
this cut for [ __ ] misha tate man i
know she's already pretty ripped oh he's
rooting for that diamond though and then
your girl mackenzie dern versus t-shirt
mackenzie dern
ufc 273 april 9th
i bet she's an underdog in that but that
that's a good fight for
yeah definitely giving these [ __ ]
stand-up specials on [ __ ] stop man
they always give her like these tough
ass matchups oh for some reason i
thought i talked about comedy for a
second no stand-up special
uh so this is kevin holland announcing
that he's gonna fight um
at 170 versus cowboy oliveira
it's kind of funny
yeah boy they got me fighting cowboy
marshman big mouth
y'all in full effect too i might come
back
is
[Music]
that was fun
this is a little different different
i agree i dig it that was fun
that was cool yeah
all right it's a good fight too so we
now know who chad mendez is going to do
his bkfc debut with it's a guy named
famez
so i had to look him up is it famous
i think i don't know
but this is his boxing record so his
name is joshua alvarez his nickname is
farmers or femmes or whatever famous
he's a dade county boy
yeah so 2-0
that's pretty good then i looked more
into it
uh he's also an r b singer yes right
he lost his last bkfc fight is that him
on the left that's him on the left and i
looked at his youtube channel hell yeah
does he have some music he's got some
music and i just started oh i can't wait
to just check this out but you want that
one or the purpose
uh where's which one's better wait so i
saw a little bit of the oh then i wish i
never stopped it okay please play it for
me is it good there's making out
he's just be he's just kissing
[Music]
jake's little titty action is that his
wife she have a ring on
how's this not get flagged
she's clear oh yeah that's his wife
literally a dime piece
uh
[Music]
do you say what's your name
i'll just get a hotel yes
oh that's not what it means just rings
[Music]
yeah you want to understand
under control
[Music]
bonafide is a video vixen
can actually see yeah
[Music]
i was ready for a [ __ ] show i thought
you were bringing up like him making i
was like this could be a disaster give
me one more all right i'm into this
[ __ ] guy femez is crushing it famous
uh yeah give me a purpose
[Music]
[Music]
i swear
[Music]
first of all as far as combat sports go
he's by far
the most talented musicians singer for
sure yeah who's better
the production like the videos are great
like talking about real [ __ ] yeah it
sounds good it's fantastic i'm a [ __ ]
fan famous
it's fantastic dude 6 000 views that's
[ __ ] i know he needs some more go
[ __ ] watch fame as it was great man
super talented yeah he's he's like he
reminds me of mike stud
so mike said the singing and rapping
right yeah okay yeah but yeah when i saw
this i was like this is like a legit
r b singer yeah dude and the music is
good
feels great there's some layers there
yeah
we got a partner up here in [ __ ]
little brown
right for sure you him and little brows
dude why not famous
i guarantee we get you more than six
thousand views son and with his talent
he's got a cool look too everything
great look yeah looks good has diamond
pieces in his videos the music videos
i'm sure he doesn't have a huge budget
but he's crushing those yeah they look
great we gotta work on the handwriting
of the people there whatever
and the lyrics are actually good yes
yeah there's some depth they're not
talking about like money and [ __ ] and
cash and fighting and knockouts yeah the
dude has some layers to him
i'm in so that's that's who dude chad
mendez is fighting famous well chad you
know i love you
well fame has more now but uh
females hit us up man we'll connect you
with little brows get it get on some
tracks with a thick boy
so that's going to be at knuckle mania 2
uh february 19th it's a tough fight for
famous it's going to be so tough dude
chad it's like a [ __ ] truck
famous dude clearly
clearly you can do this r b thing dude
yes music thing
[ __ ]
bare knuckle boxing against chad mendes
dude
you can do it yes you can it's just with
6 000 views it's gonna be tough to make
it no i know but that's why we can help
him out exactly now start blowing up
hopefully
chad hit so hard dude he's looking crazy
now
yeah quads are so juicy right there
um i wasn't familiar with not sardine
imam but uh that's who kelvin gaslin is
gonna be fighting next at ufc 273. not
doing kelvin any favors and then yeah so
he's
yeah you you know him because he uh he
beat edmond last one yeah
and highness it's a tough fight for for
kelvin yeah
speaking of another tough fight uh we
talked about this already
yaroslav amazov who's a killer he's
fighting michael page and now it's set
for bellator london main event he's just
in london though yeah but that very
tough fight wembley for michael venom
super tough yeah
god they need we got bellator needs
venom to be the face of that you know
he's yeah he's always super exciting
okay
so john no john jones daniel cormier
predicted that if john when jon jones
goes to heavyweight he'll lose to both
cyril and in ghana
i mean you gotta take this grain of salt
dude right like with their bad beef
stuff like that like we don't know how
he's gonna do uh so he's i believe that
john will fight it heavy and he'll fight
for the belt and he'll lose a serial gun
or francis i just think that the time
away the weight difference those guys
being who they are
that's the problem it's not that jon
jones has gotten worse just that these
guys are different level heavyweight i
agree i you know i agree i just feel
like
john has more tools than those guys
um
again
it's styles that make fights i think
john would have an a better chance of
winning against francis than he would um
cyril gone i think cyril gone out of any
heavyweight would be a complete
nightmare for john a guy who can move
um his athletic abilities quick he hits
harder he's long
he has a gas tank john's attributes at
heavyweight are gonna be you know
obviously his fight iq
um his wrestling especially at the top
there francis and sierra gone neither
are wrestlers so francis can take
advantage of that with both of them but
cyril's definitely tougher to take down
with his footwork
um
you know as i keep
going that you know dc has a point you
know the it we have no idea what john's
gonna look like what i don't like
is john's been out this long and he's
trying to put on weight
like i would like john be around like
230 235 because
even at light heavyweight even though
he's a bigger light heavyweight he's not
a not he doesn't knock anybody out he's
not not one punch knockout artist his
creativity his takedowns um he breaks
people's will
so
he can take that same model and bring it
to heavy weight my issue is when he
tries to put on weight and go pound for
pound with the heavyweights he's gonna
be in trouble
so even though when i first heard this
one like let's dc stone shade
he's not far off
with john i see how big he's like i'm
gonna get to 270 it's like oh well then
you're [ __ ] dude if you're trying to
go pound for pound with these big boys
who
they woke up like that and you got to do
all this training you're going to be
slower and your card is going to be
worse and you're hoping you
you know
i don't like it it's going to make them
slower because these guys they're they
were born like this so francis
especially cyril gone like
they were they couldn't cut the 205 they
have to work at heavyweights so
um
i
kind of co-signed with dc on this before
we talked about it yeah at first i
thought it was just being a hater but
kind of cosign with them
there you
go uh okay so this is
the
first of all mighty mouse is fighting a
guy named rod kang raj tang's like a
legend he's crazy too so here's a quick
highlight he's uh the more thai guy
right yeah he does alternate he goes mma
and muay thai so they're gonna be
fighting
in singapore march 26 on one
and this is just something that one of
the fights that he
it's did a show that knocked down
changed it though i think it changed it
beautiful invasion there from rock tang
so he started
work here and he bashes himself in the
chest and in the face jesus christ what
a [ __ ] savage his opponent in the
last 10 seconds
they are two 22 year old and now you're
saying
coming into play debating in the chest
the snapping of the fight well he's just
eating it [ __ ] he just lets people punch
him in the face it's kind of crazy and
he also like he does these great
takedowns as well and he's such a
monster monster monster
so that dude that's that's my mouse
and then another cool fight on that card
it's uh john lineker that's a ufc
knockout artist
john linker's guy who left the ufc and
man he's a monster yeah and bibiana
fernandez
that's fun
hold up sick hold up a second never mind
so march 26 is for dj
and raw tang and then this one's going
to be february 11th monster fights yeah
uh speaking of one they're saying
they're going to give out this thing
called the warrior bonus so basically if
you show your warrior spirit they'll
give you fifty thousand dollars there's
a minimum of one each fight but there's
a maximum of like or there's no maximum
thing or maybe five or something give
out more than one yeah warrior bonus and
now does the worry branch count like if
i knocked out in 30 seconds do i get a
warrior bonus if the guy thinks it's
worth you know warrior worthy who's the
guy
i think victor cooy
victor cory or chauchary
assume chauchi does it in the fires the
warrior
50 000 of fighters impressed me the most
in terms of throwing the fans oh they
they're i thought it was just like
showing like chin and like a warrior
spirit but okay delivering a phenomenal
finish oh oh oh one championship you
mean a
you mean what the ufc's been doing for
20 years a win bonus yeah
the warrior bonus hey guys breaking news
we came with this insane idea wheel
worth fifty thousand dollars the exact
same thing so there is one camera
fighter impressed me the most in terms
of thrilling the fans you mean a
knockout demonstrating incredible
warrior spirit you mean fight the night
exhibiting amazing skills yep dealing
with them all finish
finish of the night yeah performance of
the night they said they would give it
to a loser too as long as he shows that
warrior type of spirit yeah if he yeah
if yeah if you you know it's five of the
nights yeah pretty much the same thing
the exact same thing attention everybody
i know
now i like it the more money for the
[ __ ] is great and it's going to be dope
she wins those but i'm just saying it's
not like they're reinventing the wheel
here
but great for the fighters hell yeah
that's dope but also ufc's been known
for ten years yeah so you know what
conor mcgregor has that new restaurant
the black fortune
he has like a brick and mortar yep and
it's in dublin it looks pretty dope too
but i guess some random dudes came over
and threw some molokov molotov cocktails
at him bad criminals though because
after hours it appears the crimsons made
an unprovoked effort to inflict damage
to the black forge inn there was no
damage done to any patrons employers of
the forge and mr mcgregor was not on the
premise at the time of the incident
um yeah they're still looking for him
and this is from madison may they just i
guess they capture one of connor's
stories and he just looks crazy jacked
here
oh my god that boy
like the hulk
yeah he's fired up a lot of energy there
too yeah it kind of makes you think he's
i'm having some fun yeah my whiskey
doesn't give you that energy you guys
makes you a little more excited for that
energy maybe take proper and something
else huh sometimes yeah what uh what you
gonna call it henry sudo said
i thought this was super funny this is
uh your favorite was talking to ariel
about
a random text that chill would send
cause chills i guess sends crazy text
out you might have
had some weird text too i don't know i
don't send out word text no no to chill
sends to them so yeah i guess one of
them was uriah just lost this big title
fight or whatever and then uh this is
what chill said
uh you're right i'm sorry for your last
i've never lost can't relate you're just
trying to make it i know it's just so
funny yeah i love funny dude because
when you lose you get all these texts
like i'm so sorry i mean you get them
next time yeah but it'd be funny to get
uh you're right i'm sorry for your last
i've never lost okay like which would
make you laugh of course you're like
bringing you joy for sure that's great
that's awesome
so yeah
i thought okay so laura senko it was
said that she would be on the desk as a
color commentator commentating desk
analyst but then i watched it and she
wasn't on their brush she was on that
actual desk desk with
you know anthony leinhardt i don't want
karen bryant yes we want her actually at
the booth right so are they going to do
the booth no i mean maybe in the future
but i thought that was going to happen
this time but it wasn't so what'd they
do they just had her oh like like the
analyst destino bryant used to do yeah
they still use karen bryan so she was
with there with karen bryant and uh
anthony smith yeah bro obviously brian's
great karen brian i've worked with a
million times i love her but they should
uh
they need to put her in the booth yeah
like she's the only one who can do in
the booth yeah
like her skills speak for themselves ufc
put her in the booth and this isn't even
a matter of being woke in 2022 and women
the same i don't play that [ __ ]
skill for skill talent for talent she's
good as anybody do put her in the
[ __ ] booth man
that's a shame i bet you they will
though i think eventually they will
she's great she's yeah she was and she
fought too so that's put in the [ __ ]
booth
um
so brian kelleher or boy brian boom
he said he actually shirted before the
walkout so he had to go back real quick
and clean up
and he won the fight by the way he said
don't tell anybody hilarious
i guess him i had to fart and then you
know yeah it happens dude especially
you're nervous
it never happened to me but yeah i feel
you have you ever had anything i always
have to pee i was like [ __ ] and then
once you like i have to pee so bad like
dude you're walking out in literally a
minute you don't have time to pee
but then it just goes away but when
you're nourishing it you pee a lot so
you're peeing every [ __ ] three
minutes backstage you're not you're
drinking a ton of water you're not
drinking you're trying to but not really
okay that's a beast you never had any
type of digestion never uh never think
not rocky then yeah i'm opposite
yeah there's a girl that actually chat
in the cage yeah i've seen that yeah
also like on this carnivore diet rogan
sweat like he talks about the only thing
was the diarrhea
nothing
i mean my stool is like a dark black
but it's not like
dark like i was like well here comes the
[ __ ] diarrhea party
nothing maybe it takes time my body says
man we got this fam we've been waiting
for this we ain't gonna ruin your day
with diarrhea everyone's like sometimes
i can barely
you know i'm worried about [ __ ] my pants
so i was like all right well maybe get
some depends or let's load up dude i
don't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about
but the black you might want to ask your
doctor about the blackness
i think it's just because it's all meat
all red meat no veggies nothing
[Music]
all right well
hopefully you're good one ticket to
shredville via black [ __ ]
uh so this is the last one this is uh
this is in russia
and
so the guy is fighting a girl the girl
is a plus size model the guy is a porn
star
right
all right
there's a this is what i got from this
story so the guy's porn star so he was
putting her in a choke
she's a russian porn star yeah
and she's a plus size model there it
says plus size blogger oh she's also a
model i saw it on a different uh article
nothing doper than a full-size model
yeah and then when you tell your kid
they can do anything and then you're
gonna like you know if your kid's chubby
she's like oh i'll be a model now you're
like [ __ ] yeah yeah back in the day like
absolutely not you can be a fighter now
yeah whatever you want to do
so as is happening wait hold on how did
it how did this get sanctioned a guy
versus a girl i don't know it's it's
time to be it's been done before
we saw that girl beat the show that big
guy and by the way she won after this so
she's one and one in her career okay
so i'll play this for you some random
dude didn't like the fact that this
guy's
hitting a girl and he jumped in and
tried to actually kick him i'll show you
does she have any training yeah
[Applause]
did he step
[Music]
oh
that guy's probably a friend of hers
right
that guy came he tried to do an actual
foot stomp on that guy that referee got
him not in there he did campaign with
tumbled him yeah not up in here dude
is that your friend yeah i'm guessing it
has to be some sort of relationship
there's no way you're that passionate
about plus-sized models where you're
gonna jump into [ __ ]
without not having some sort of
relationship with her also she she
seemed fine yeah she was like yeah she
was an awful position clearly because
she's plus-sized model fighting mma but
uh your face wasn't [ __ ] up or
anything like that
weird russia gonna rush him and that's
fantastic exactly is that it that's it
great show guys
um yeah man
you know the deal
i've ranted for damn near 30 minutes on
the magnitude that francis ingano has to
to [ __ ] win this saturday
january 22nd man you got ufc 270. i
don't give a [ __ ] about anybody else how
about that the main event franciano
cyril gone
for the world heavyweight title
and the magnitude of francis the change
of the game forever is on the line there
will be a calabasas fight campaign 7 pm
live on thick boy with brian callan
crystalia myself tune into that i can't
wait enjoy the fights uh as far as uh
road date stuff like that i have one
show on the 26th in los angeles
california the hollywood improv that bad
[ __ ] is almost sold out shop and
friends there's been a bunch of monsters
on that show we will sell out so get
your tickets right now there's 25
tickets left
and then other than that uh sacramento
california february 24th through the
26th at the punch line in sacramento
tickets for chicago just went on sale
march 24th through march 26th i will see
my boy george out there who is down to
206 pounds now
shout out to big george so chicago's
march 24th through march 26th please
don't snow uh
but yeah so you got the 26 in hollywood
improv you have the 24th through 26th of
february at the punchline sacramento and
then next saturday january 29th you have
the tough mudder 10 a.m lake elsinore
sign up uh for the thick mudder you can
run with me and my boys 15k promise you
to get through it we're all gonna be a
team help each other out it's gonna be a
great time come on out next saturday and
that's it man i will see you guys either
uh on tour around la doing stand up or
if not stay safe stay thick love you
guys i'm out